mein Thema heute Abend ist ein anderes
und zwar ist es die flüchtlingskrise XXL
die Deutschland trifft wer noch vor
kurzem sagte dass dieses Jahr noch mal
Flüchtlinge kommen als 2015 wurde als
Schwarzmaler deformiert doch nun haben
wir die harten Zahlen auf dem Tisch und
es sieht gar nicht gut aus ist ein
bisschen September mehr Flüchtlinge nach
Deutschland gekommen als im Gesamtjahr
2015 allein aus der Ukraine wurden fast
eine Million Menschen registriert
zusätzlich kam 100.000 Flüchtlinge aus
Russland Tunesien dem Libanon und aus
Afrika über die Türkei und die
Balkanroute nach Deutschland schon jetzt
fürchten deutsche Kommunen
unterbringungsengpässe im Winter in
Österreich nähern sie sie zahlen denen
des Krisenjahres 2015 meine erste Frage
ist eine Politiker hier in der Runde
Herr dohrendorf schaffen wir das
das ist schwierig wir sehen uns ja jetzt
eher schon zu Hause in den Gemeinden das
einfach kein Wohnraum erfahren ist wir
sind gerade dabei wir bekommen in
Lüchow-Dannenberg so circa 25 30
Flüchtlinge jede Woche und die hören
dann halt einfach mit dem Bus einfach
ich sage jetzt mal
abgestellt und dann müssen wir sehen wie
wir sie unterbringen es geht jetzt
soweit dass wir wahrscheinlich
Turnhallen wieder herrichten müssen das
hat auch wieder Probleme die Schüler
können ihre ihre ihren Unterricht Sport
nicht mehr machen die Vereine können
wieder keine keine Wettbewerbe
durchführen das sind ja nur die kleinen
Probleme aber wir haben einfach keine
keine Wohnung mehr wir haben jetzt
gerade ein ein wirklich nicht sehr
schönes Haus hergerichtet
das haben mal die Chinesen gekauft
tatsächlich und die kriegen jetzt
750.000 im Jahr an
Miete unglaublich weil sie einfach keine
Möglichkeit
750.000 Euro Miete für ein Jahr ja und
das ein Haus sie haben wie viel
Wohnungen sind denn in dem Haus drin 50
Leute passen da rein für die
Unterbringung 50 Menschen es ist so dass
die was läuft in der falsch es kommt mir
sehr hoch vor wir sind verzweifelt wo
wollen wir sie hinbringen also weil wir
gesagt haben die Turnhallen das ist ja
eine Katastrophe Familien in die
Turnhalle unterzubringen da sind nur
leichte Wände dass er das überhaupt
keine keine
Familienatmosphäre möglich und darum
haben wir gesagt wir müssen es irgendwo
anders machen das Problem ist diese
Chinesen haben ein altes Schlachthaus
gekauft und da waren halt viele Gebäude
dabei und ein Gebäude richtet jetzt
gerade die Gesamtgemeinde her und dann
werden die Flüchtlinge da untergebracht
und dann wird gezeigt der Vertrag läuft
über zwei Jahre
ich fand das trifft er direkt die Leute
die wenig Geld haben die bei uns im Land
wohnen zwar ganz egal ob immer schon
Deutsch oder mit Migrationshintergrund
die sieht ja gerade die Opfer weil
natürlich Vermieter werden sich sagen
ich vermute doch lieber für solche
Preise an den Staat als irgendwelchen
Familien die gar nicht so viel bezahlen
können da müssen wir einfach mal auf der
Spur gehen was da falsch läuft beim
Start also ein Steuerzahler muss ich
sagen 750.000 für ein Jahr für 50
Flüchtlinge das ist sehr viel ja
aber Herr Geiges wenn ich sie fragen
darf kommen denn da Erinnerung bei Ihnen
an 2015 hoch
naja auf jeden Fall und das Problem ist
ja also ich bin ja sehr dafür dass wir
brauchen ja Menschen aus der ganzen Welt
weil unsere Gesellschaft überaltet aber
das wird überhaupt nicht angegangen es
wird halt die humanitäre Hilfe für das
sind ja nur zum kleineren Teil jetzt
politisch verfolgt aber halt für
Kriegsflüchtlinge und so weiter und so
weiter oder für Leute die aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen kommen aber das
was eigentlich gebraucht würde dass man
gezielt Leute holt die auch hier was tun
können wir haben sie gerade gesehen
Flughäfen und so weiter ich meine wir
haben so viele Leute obwohl Jobs gibt es
ja genug ich möchte unterbrechen aber
wir haben ja gerade über 500.000 freie
Stellen vor allem auch in einfachen
Tätigkeiten das heißt eigentlich
benötigen wir die Flüchtlinge der
Economist hat mal geschätzt dass wir
400.000 Flüchtlinge pro Jahr als
Zuwanderung auch brauchen aber offenbar
wird das falsch organisiert weil sonst
wäre die Jobs besetzt es kommen die
falschen Leute wir haben eine negativ
Selektion
die Zahl in der Schweiz sind so dass von
allen Flüchtlingen 84% Sozialhilfe
beziehen längerfristig also über viele
Jahre Weg nicht einfach am angefangen 16
% arbeiten nur nur 60% arbeitet alle
anderen sind langfristig vom Staat
abhängig das heißt von anderen
Steuerzahlern von der Nachbarn und das
kann das nicht sein also wir haben eine
völlig blinde Asylpolitik und ich meine
dass das Wort das sozialtourismus ist
völlig richtig es sind es sind
Wirtschaftsmigranten sich nicht dafür
entschuldigen müssen auf keinen Fall das
ist eine Beschreibung der Realität das
trifft einfach in vielen Fällen zu man
kann sogar noch weitergehen und sagen
das ist ja es hat also das
matratzerisches man kommt Hermann Nüsse
Sozialsystem aus aber ich will nicht mal
unbedingt Flüchtlingen den Vorwurf
machen sondern unser Politik wir sind
dafür verantwortlich dass wir das nicht
zulassen ich habe selbst recherchiert in
China Artikel zum Beispiel auch die
Ausweispflicht oder man kommt normaler
Menschen weisen sich aus beiden jungen
Flüchtlingen unter 18-Jährigen ist so
dass 697% Pass wegwerfen sich gar nicht
richtig ausweisen und wenn Leib und
Leben verfolgt sind und das ist der
Definition
dann haben Sie Interesse an die
Identität offenzulegen und offenbar wird
das nicht gemacht das zeigt schon dass
das sehr viel einfach auch betrogen wird
und dass das ist sicher nicht richtig
wenn ich jetzt mal gegen Argument wagen
wollen würde kann es auch einfach sein
dass sowohl Schweiz auch als Deutschland
keine Integration können ich meine die
Menschen sind da die Arbeit ist da sind
wir vielleicht auch einfach zu blöd für
Integration
stehen die herkommen weil es wird alles
bezahlt dass wir in Dolmetscher bezahlt
dass wir dies und das bezahlt
ebensozialausgaben und es ist schon wenn
man ein fremdes Land geht gehen Sie mal
nach China kommt vielleicht auch darauf
gehen sie nach Vietnam und sagen Sie
dort ich liebe diesen Staat leben die
lachen ja nur ich meine das ist schon
eine eine merkwürdige Mentalität
nach Deutschland zum Beispiel 2015 da
habe ich auch mal undercover in einem
Flüchtlingsheim gearbeitet und da muss
ich ihn ganz ehrlich sagen aus meinen
Erfahrungen damals auch die Menschen die
arbeiten wollten die durften ja gar
nicht weil das ist ja auch ganz
bürokratisch hier in unserem Land es
gibt ja auch Flüchtlinge die zu uns
kommen und die einfach nicht dürfen ich
hoffe bei Ukrainern geht das jetzt
schneller da würde ich gerne Herr
dohrendorf fragen was ich da verbessert
hat ja leider wir mein großes Problem
und zwar ist es halt so man muss
arbeitslos sein damit man diesen diesen
Deutschkurs mitmachen kann der kostet
1200 bis 2000 €. wenn ich nicht
Arbeitslosen darf ich Dir nicht machen
wir haben aber genügend Leute die würden
20 Stunden gerne arbeiten in der Pflege
in anderen Bereichen weil sie auch zu
Hause in der Pflege oder in ihrem
Berufen gearbeitet haben dürfen sie aber
nicht weil sie sonst diesen Kurs nicht
umsonst bekommen und das und das ist
eigentlich also warum man das so so so
formuliert aber das ist so typisch
deutsch das ist nicht zu Ende gedacht
wenn ich also ein ein Job habe bis 450
Euro darf ich das aber wenn ich 20
Stunden arbeite geht's eben nicht und
das funktioniert eben nicht weil wir
genügend Stellen haben wie wir besetzen
wollen als Medienwissenschaftler wie
blicken sie auf die flüchtlingskrise und
wie berichten wir auch die Medien
darüber
ja ich denke und sie haben das ja schon
angesprochen es gibt eben doch in
Deutschland eine sehr sehr tiefgehende
Ängstlichkeit Probleme der Integration
anzusprechen und die Medien sind leider
Gottes nicht auf der Seite der
Aufklärung was das betrifft wie in
vielen anderen Themenbereichen ja leider
auch also wir haben gerade was das Thema
Migration Massenmigration betrifft auch
aus historischen Gründen sehr viele
Tabus bei der Thematisierung und das
macht natürlich das bürokratische
abwickeln solcher Probleme
außerordentlich schwierig ich sehe es
genauso wie sie das ist eben nicht nur
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge gibt die dann
womöglich tatsächlich nur Hartz IV oder
irgendetwas einstreichen wollen sondern
sehr viele Leute die auch gerne arbeiten
würden und durchaus auch qualifiziert
sind und das ist ein bürokratischen
Problemen scheitert aber ich denke wir
kommen wirklich nur weiter wenn wir da
bin ich fast schon bei meinem eigenen
Thema von heute wenn wir das auch
tatsächlich diskutieren die Probleme
diskutieren offen ansprechen und nicht
so der auf dieses Problem hinweist
sofort als Nazi abkanzeln denn das ist
ja das große Problem dass gerade
Massenmigration bei uns mit dem wenn Sie
so wollen Nazi Tabu belegt ist also
jeder wird dagegen ist gegen eine
vollkommene Offenheit also ein
vollkommene Grenzenlosigkeit des zu